welcome to pymol 101 with molecular
memory I'm KP and in this lesson we'll
learn about selection using the protein
Carbonic anhydrase carbon dioxide is a
waste product produced by our cells
only a small percentage of this gas
dissolves directly in blood plasma
some is carry by hemoglobin but about 70
percent of it is reacted by Carbonic
anhydrase and carried to the lungs as
water soluble bicarbonate ions
in the lungs Carbonic anhydrase reverses
the reaction remaking carbon dioxide
which we breathe out in lesson one we
learn to load the biological unit of
macromolecules
file get pdb type 3 u y n
set the assembly to 1 and click download
here's Carbonic anhydrase display the
sequence and we're ready to model
from the rcsb page we can access the
manuscript describing this structure
some manuscripts are behind a paywall
but this is where I found one that gave
numbers for the important amino acids in
this lesson's structure
real quick some terminology
an enzyme is a protein that performs a
chemical reaction making or breaking
covalent bonds
the active site is the part of an enzyme
where a chemical reaction takes place
and it is made up of amino acids when we
refer to amino acids in a protein we
often call them residues
back to business we're going to create
and save separate selections for zinc
the active site residues and the water
molecules that interact with the active
site
scrolling through our sequence we have
the amino acid one letter codes a zinc
ion and Waters
click on zinc either in the sequence or
by clicking on the gray sphere on the
structure in the structure viewer window
the letters s-e-l-e come up in the names
panel
click a next to them and choose rename
selection
now in the upper left hand side of the
structure viewer window a prompt comes
up
delete the letters s-e-l-e and type a
new name I'll call this zinc
now very important click somewhere in
the blank space in the structure viewer
window to clear the selection
otherwise the next object you click on
will be added to the zinc selection
now let's select the amino acid residues
that make up Carbonic anhydrases active
site
using the sequence display scroll back
to the amino acids
I'll put the list of amino acids we need
on screen
first we're looking for residue 5.
notice that residue 6 is labeled so
residue 5 is this tryptophan just to the
left of it
click on it to select
next we need residue 7.
then n62 be careful there's another n
asparagine right next to it so be sure
you select the correct one
k64 next
then h67
now h94
91 2 3 4.
next up is h96
and let's stop here at histidine 119.
if it makes it easier for you you can
use the display drop down menu to change
the sequence mode to show three letter
codes
now I don't because I like the way I can
see breaks in the sequence with the one
letter codes to easily identify
different protein chains and ligands
notice in the object panel the letters
s-e-l-e have popped up again
rename this to active a button rename
delete s-e-l-e and type active
click in the blank space of the
structure viewer window to clear the
selection
but oh no we forgot to residues
no problem just click on active again in
the names panel to select it with this
selected we can add the missing residues
buying threonine 199 and 200 in the
sequence and click on them
added click in the blank space
active site selection complete
selecting active site residues with the
command line is way faster
here's the command on screen you can
pause if you're interested
the different ways we represent
structures are called renderings
in pimel the protein is shown as a
cartoon rendering by default
it makes sense to show our active site
residues in a way that lets us see the
atoms though since they'll interact with
the reactants as the chemical reaction
takes place
add stick rendering to show the active
site residues next to active in the
names panel click s for show and select
sticks
what pymol is doing is layering
representations on top of each other
now let's see what show as does
active s
show as sticks whoa parts of the protein
cartoon get chopped out let's not do
that click s next to active and add the
cartoon back in
let's zoom in on the active site
namespanel active a zoom
notice how parts of the structure fade
some clipping has been applied check out
video one for a description of clipping
and how to adjust it
highmall can automatically find the
interactions that polar atoms make
find active in the names panel
click a
find
polar contacts to any atoms
notice yellow dotted lines show the
interactions
let's do the same for zinc
a find polar contacts to any atoms
now we have two different sets of
contacts in the names panel
notice some water molecules have
interactions with the active site amino
acid residues and zinc
let's select them by clicking on them in
the structure
rotate and zoom as needed to find them
all
now save this selection
a rename delete s-e-l-e and let's call
this Active water
now we'll hide the rest of the water in
the structure
next to 3uyn click the hide button H
Waters
but we do want to show Waters in the
active site next to Active water s
spheres
this applies a rendering called space
fill
but the waters look huge and might
obstruct parts of the active site
let's resize them using a preset pymol
has built in
next to Active water a preset ball and
stick
Ah that's much better the interactions
look bad because some of them look like
they're going to nowhere
they're actually contacting residues or
Waters we haven't shown
I'll show you how to fix that in an
episode on measurement but for now let's
just turn them off by deselecting them
in the names panel when we display amino
acids as sticks pymol shows the atoms
that make up both the backbone and side
chain
the backbone atoms connect the groups
that form new covalent bonds when the
protein is made
and the side chain is the variable group
The R Group on that specific amino acid
we can show or hide each of these
separately so next to active select H
main chain that hides the backbone
to add it back in show main chain sticks
we've done a ton of work Ctrl s to save
this Primal session somewhere on your
computer
we'll use it in lesson three hope to see
you next time